قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
ان الاداره الامريكيه تركز جهودها المكثفه
على استعاده الاسرى لدى حماس مشيرا الى
مواصله العمل مع كل من قطر ومصر في هذا
المسعى كما اضاف بلينكن خلال مقابله مع
قناه ام اس ان بي سي اضاف ان الجهود منصبه
كذلك على تجديد فترات التهد واعاده
المفاوضات بشان الاسرى الى المسار
الصحيح نحنا منذ بضعه اشهر في اخراج اكثر
من 100 رهينه نحن مصممون جدا على مواصله
ذلك ونحن منخرطون بشكل مكثف في هذا الجهد
حاليا لتجديد فترات التهدئه واطلاق سراح
الرهائن وهذا يكتسي اهميه خاصه لاداره
بايدن وهذا ما شاركته مع العائلات الجزء
الصعب هو ان العدو حماس لديها كلمه في هذا
الموضوع لذلك فاننا نبذل كل ما في وسعنا
نعمل بالطبع مع الاسرائيل
ونعمل مع قطر ونعمل مع مصر والدول التي
لها علاقات من نوع او اخر مع حماس لاعاده
هذا الامر الى المسار الصحيح ومواصله
اعاده الرهائن الى
وطنهم